el momento de actualizar la información
económica en france 24 y nos acompaña
por supuesto daniela a blandón daríamos
a comenzar hablando de las propuestas
económicas no del nuevo virtual
presidente ecuatoriano santiago hola
buenas noches mire guillermo lasso quien
llegaría el próximo 24 de mayo al
palacio de carondelet no terminó sus
estudios universitarios pero sí tiene un
alto perfil económico es accionista del
banco de guayaquil del que también fue
presidente y además fue ministro de
economía en 1999 el banquero de 65 años
ya dio las primeras pistas de lo que era
en términos económicos lo hizo este
lunes al prometer que no aumentara el
impuesto al valor agregado y dijo que
eliminará el déficit fiscal en 4 años
también anunció que pretende realizar
ciertos cambios en los nuevos contratos
petroleros entretanto el programa
económico que presentó durante su
campaña dice que mantendrá la economía
dolarizada que creará 2 millones de
empleos y que buscará elevar el salario
básico a 500 dólares desde los actuales
pero también tiene la tarea de
solucionar los problemas de liquidez y
la enorme deuda pública santiago además
ahora un tema muy interesante que tiene
que ver con que naciones unidas estaría
viendo un 'impuesto de solidaridad' para
lo más rico no algo que suele ser
difícil no en algunos intentos que han
hecho en varios países sin santiago de
hecho hay dos propuestas similares que
se están discutiendo en el plano mundial
en este momento una es la que hizo eeuu
a imponer una tasa mínima de impuesto
corporativo y ahora llega esta
iniciativa de naciones unidas lo invito
a que la escuchemos los informes más
recientes indican que ha habido un
aumento en 5 billones de dólares en la
fortuna de los más ricos del mundo
durante el último año instó a los
gobiernos a que consideren un impuesto a
la solidaridad o patrimonio de quienes
se han beneficiado durante la pandemia
para reducir las desigualdades extremas
santiago bien en varios países de la
región ya lo han hecho argentina lo
aprobó hace poco chile méxico y eeuu lo
están apenas discutiendo y en colombia
existe hace muchos años este impuesto
así es y es algo que suele tener
bastante resistencia cambiamos ahora de
información hablemos última que preocupa
a muchísimas personas también empresas
que tienen
con la escasez global de chips no una
preocupación que ahora se instala en la
casa blanca- sí pues mire este fenómeno
que se hizo más fuerte en la pandemia
afecta desde la fabricación de toda
clase de aparatos tecnológicos desde
celulares pasando por computadores y
consolas de juego hasta relojes
inteligentes pero la industria más
afectada ha sido la de los vehículos
cuyos fabricantes han tenido que
recortar su producción en algunas
fábricas de américa del norte este lunes
el tema fue discutido por el presidente
joe biden y los directores de 19
empresas
chips como el que tengo aquí son
baterías banda ancha infraestructura
entonces tenemos que construir la
infraestructura de hoy no repararla de
ayer
durante mucho tiempo como nación no
hemos estado haciendo las grandes y
audaces inversiones que necesitamos para
superar a nuestros competidores globales
nos hemos quedado atrás en investigación
en desarrollo y fabricación para decirlo
sin rodeos tenemos que intensificar
nuestro huevo daniela no vas a informar
ahora sobre un tema que está llamando la
atención porque los presidentes de las
grandes empresas de wall street- vieron
aumentado sus salarios en el año 2020 el
año de la gran crisis y no la de
santiago todo recordaremos que la bolsa
de nueva york ha venido superando
récords récord durante la pandemia pero
asimismo lo ha hecho el salario promedio
de sus presidentes que se ha disparado
en un 7 por ciento de acuerdo con un
informe del diario the wall street
journal la compensación media de cada
presidente fue de 13,7 millones de
dólares frente a 12,8 millones del
ejercicio anterior
me dice que el alza benefició a los
ejecutivos de 206 de 322 compañías
analizadas ahora escuché esto santiago
ellos concluyen diciendo que los
recortes de salario que muchos de los
ejecutivos se aplicaron pues para dar
ejemplo durante la crisis tuvieron poco
impacto porque la mayor parte del
ingreso viene en forma de acciones o
bonos y no precisamente del sueldo ahora
qué nos dicen los indicadores de la
jornada de unidad hubo cierre rojo para
la bolsa de nueva york en una jornada
con poco movimiento el mercado está muy
pendiente de los resultados
empresariales del primer trimestre en
europa hubo un comportamiento similar
con excepción de milán y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo anotó su
mejor día desde el 18 de febrero y cuál
es la cifra del día 19 mil 700 millones
de dólares que microsoft anunció en la
compra de new ens una firma de
reconocimiento de voz e inteligencia
virtual santiago muchísimas gracias
daniela llegamos al fin de esta crónica
de economía los invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación gracias por acompañarnos